gefällt dir das haus gefällt dir das
haus ja das ist ein schönes haus
ja das ist ein schönes haus
ja du hast ein schönes haus
gefällt dir die wohnung gefällt dir die
wohnung
ja das ist eine schöne wohnung
ja du hast deine schöne wohnung
[Musik]
gefällt dir der tisch gefällt dir der
tisch ja das ist ein schöner tisch ja
das ist ein schöner tisch
ja du hast einen schönen tisch
[Musik]
gefallen dir die stühle
ja und das sind schöne stühle
ja das sind schöne stühle
ja du hast schöne stühle gekauft
der film ist lustig der film ist lustig
das ist ein lustiger film
das ist ein lustiger film ich sehe einen
lustigen film
ich sehe einen lustigen film
ich lache über den lustigen film ich
lache über den lustigen film
das lied ist langweilig
das ist ein langweiliges lied
ich höre ein langweiliges lied
ich höre ein langweiliges lied ich mag
keine langweiligen lieder
ich mag keine langweiligen lieder
die wohnung ist hell
das ist eine helle wohnung
ich habe eine helle wohnung
[Musik]
ich wohne in einer hellen wohnung
das zimmer ist dunkel
das ist ein dunkles zimmer
es gibt ein dunkles zimmer
ich schlage
in einem dunklen zimmer
ich schlafe in einem dunklen zimmer
der tisch ist robust
das ist ein robuster stuhl
[Musik]
ich setze mich auf den robusten stuhl
ich sitze auf einem robusten stuhl
mein sofa ist bequem
[Musik]
mainz
wahr ist bequem
das ist ein bequemes sofa dass sie
ist ein bequemes sofa
ich habe
ein bequemes sofa
ich habe ein bequemes sofa ich liege
bei einem bequemen sofa
ich liege auf einem bequemen sofa
[Musik]
der mann ist nett der mann ist mit das
ist ein netter mann
das ist ein netter mann
ich grüße einen netten mann
ich spreche gern mit einem netten mann
die frau ist nett
die frau ist nett das ist eine nette
frau
das ist eine nette frau
ich grüße ein
ich grüße eine nette frau
ich spreche gern mit einer netten frau
das kind ist nett
das kind ist nett das ist ein nettes
kind
das ist ein nettes kind ich grüße ein
nettes kind ich grüße ein nettes kind
ich spreche gern mit einem netten kind
die nachbarn
nat die nachbarn sind nett
das sehen
nette nachbarn
das sind nette nachbarn
ich grüße nette nachbarn
ich spreche gerne mit netten nachbarn
ich suche einen blauen pullover
er kaufte ein gelbes hemd
ich möchte eine elegante hose am
probieren
ich möchte eine elegante hose
anprobieren
er trägt schwarze socken
schwarze socken bei derart
muss sich immer einen dunklen anzug
tragen bei dir
tragen
in der freizeit trage ich gerne einen
weiten pullover in der freizeit trage
ich gerne einen weiten pullover tom
trägt ein rotes hemd tom trägt ein rotes
hemd
ich kaufe ein blaues t shirt
ich kaufe ein blaues t shirt an der
hochzeit trage ich ein elegantes kleid
tiago möchte eine gelbe krawatte kaufen
sie eine warme jacke an sie eine warme
jacke an
im winter tragen die leute warme mützen
im winter trage ich immer dicke
handschuhe im winter trage ich immer
dicke handschuhe
habt ihr da
video gefallen aber nie ihre unseren
kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal